ladies and gentlemen this is an
emergency episode of marketing mondays
not on a monday welcome back ladies and
gentlemen to the 10 million dollar
studio today we're talking
about burger king they just tweeted out
a whopper have you seen it what do you
think of it
here it is guys i'm gonna warn you right
now cover your ears cover your eyes if
you don't want to see
pure sexism women
belong in the kitchen guys i know i
can't believe it they've been hiding in
front of us this whole time
except when you click on it it was
actually supposed to be like an
oopsy gotcha like oops we actually
want to draw awareness of the fact that
only 20 of chefs are women and we want
to give away
scholarships now what does this have to
do with marketing
mondays here's the deal if you're gonna
craft an offensive tweet
right your strategy better be hey people
might see it and react to it you craft
the first tweet like it's not like you
didn't have room under the fold to
explain like in the first tweet that
it's a joke
instead you craft the first tweet to be
incendiary and when people get upset
what do you think you're supposed to do
well it would seem like if this was your
strategy
you would just sort of be like oh we're
sparking a conversation we're kind of
based right we're edgy we're edgy burger
king now i guess that's the direction
they seem to want to go
that could be a strategy at least it's a
strategy
instead they do this weird thing where
it seemed like they were going in this
direction
and then they pivot in the middle of the
day
to this we hear you we got our initial
tweet wrong
and we're sorry oh yes the apology's
coming out
now let me tell you why this is stupid
you knew
that you were gonna tweet something
offensive people got
upset right because it's an offensive
tweet it sounds terrible whatever
it's also kind of fun like i saw it i
first saw it i was shocked i clicked on
it because i was like no way that's got
to be a hack
and then i kind of laughed because i saw
what they were doing and i was like well
that's kind of cheesy that's kind of
dumb whatever i saw people were getting
upset i knew
because if you tweet that people will
get upset that's
what happens and that's obviously their
strategy was like we're gonna create
some controversy we're gonna be spicy
burger king today we're gonna put some
spice on the menu we're gonna be
flavor town baby are we in flavor town
right now aim at customs
spicy meat yeah boy okay you got some
flavor
you got your flavor now stick to your
guns even if your guns are
well we were just kind of like you know
being a little bit edgy whatever
it nobody really cares it's a burger
king nobody goes to burger king
for their opinion on women everyone
knows you go to burger king for a heart
attack
that's the way it is and it's the way it
always has been
ever since i've been a young boy it's
like do you want to go to her burger
king
oh yeah i actually wanted a triple
bypass today that's fine that's what we
all do is what we all know
for burger king to be like we're gonna
be edgy and then go we're sorry
how can you be sorry for getting what
you want i just have no respect
for this i mean i'm not saying i approve
of any part of their marketing strategy
but
it this is a non strategy which is we
decided to lead the
uh original tweet after apology it was
brought to our attention that there were
abusive comments in the thread and we
don't want to leave space
open for that hey burger king if you
didn't want to leave space
open for people responding to women
belong in the kitchen
you shouldn't have said women belong in
the kitchen
i don't know maybe just just a thought
i love how they're like we couldn't
believe that there were offensive
comments underneath there it's like yeah
you did it
people are dunking on you and
what's the deal here bud this had to be
approved by like 10 different people you
don't
look normally i get it they're interns
running all these accounts it's like
this dystopia where it's like 15 year
olds running wendy's
i understand that i'm not an idiot but
in the case of like
you don't just tweet women belong in the
kitchen unless
you're ready to you have a marketing
strategy and that was clear because they
rolled out a sponsorship or a
scholarship
with it but my point is is this was
planned it was calculated it probably
ran past like eight different board
members
and you know these people are sitting at
a round table what's the worst that can
happen
how could you be shocked you already
consider the worst can happen is like it
goes viral and people are mad i actually
understand zero percent of this
which is why it's going on as on
marketing mondays as what not
to do listen there are a lot of
marketing strategies
but the strategies all involve
commitment
if you're going to be uh you know a
company that's like really into
political issues
you want to be ben and jerry's that's
your thing there's nothing wrong with
that that's your thing though
if you want to be like hey we're just
corporate we're just
hella corporate everything is like
minimalistic design we just don't have a
soul that's fine
don't pretend you're anything you're not
you commit to whatever your marketing
strategy
is you commit and for sure what you do
even if you're gonna pivot you don't
let everyone know that because then you
just look weak your brand looks out of
control
commit to the strategy and i know it's
like hard you're taking heat on social
media
i get it everyone thinks you're clown
that could be the start of your rebrand
right you want to be edgy burger now
edgy burgers whatever
i just don't see how they could have not
thought this through
because i know how these companies work
they hire
whole pr firms whole marketing teams by
the way like 50 people's heads are going
to roll for this
but uh they hire whole marketing teams
to approve this stuff and they go look
we've done the studies
everyone thought this whatever we're
fine and then to back down within a day
when they probably planned this thing
out by the way for like three months
they were like dude we're gonna get them
on international women's day
they're not gonna know what hit them
well i'll tell you who didn't know what
hit them it was burger king
you really just like kind of like lose
both people
who support you when you back down this
quickly
and by the way like i want to be clear
on this because i'm not saying nobody
can get things wrong and realize they're
wrong
but what i am saying so i want to be
clear about this they got the reaction
they were planning to get that's so
important
it wasn't like they released the tweet
and then someone goes oh my god
we worded the tweet wrong i can't
believe it was interpreted this way
they knew they had the exact
interpretation this is so
stupid they got the exact interpretation
and reaction
they wanted and drafted the tweet to get
and then we're like wow this is way too
much we've got to apologize and
backtrack
that's what i'm trying to say they knew
i would be interpreted
but i knew burger king was out to lunch
because i was like dude we've got to do
some investigation this is the internet
detective
here and i realized i saw their tweet i
kept reading and i got like i got a read
of the room
and i realized oh these guys really
don't know what's going on and they're
saying
now more than ever we believe that fresh
good quality food is vital
to the quality of our lives i was one
sentence in and i said
oh delusional you're not a michelin star
restaurant
you're a burger king and they're like
good for the planet good for people good
for gas good for communities animal
welfare
burger king that's cool you're none of
those things
you're the guys who invented the chicken
fries
nothing about this is good for humans
animals the community
you probably had to dig up an oil well
in the marianas trench
to find oil thick enough to coat these
fries i mean my point is
is that such a great example of what not
to do
and i know they're getting attention for
this either way and you could say like
well
even the apology is part of the pr it's
not they look really weak here
if you're gonna be spicy you gotta be
prepared
for people to say hey that's a little
too hot we don't like that
otherwise stay stay in the mild section
stay in the mail
that's what i do listen family friendly
channel here
never done anything controversial never
will you come to my channel
you're getting some some white
spreadable mail
baby that's my brand family friendly we
respect women
on this channel so let me know if you
enjoyed i just wanted to get this out
there because i think it's so topical
and uh thanks for watching i'll see you
in the next
wake up one the coffee